[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon six boys
what's up fam welcome it's Monday
morning January 16th on this crisp Chris
Los Angeles morning how's everybody
doing you're on your way to work
dropping the kiddos off at school
dropping those Gremlins off
uh well you're not because it's a
holiday it's Martin Luther King day
isn't it so I think all schools have off
so parents if you're listening at home
the kids are
kind of uh you know being too loud you
can't probably hear me so
um hope you can turn the volume up or
whatever because when kids have the day
off for parents it's a nightmare
entertain those little bastards 24 7.
they don't stop can't stop won't stop
they're kids everyone's doing well huh
that's cool man a lot of rain here in
California huh we need it uh that's what
old people say but we do need it the
ficuses are popping the fish are good
I'm glad you guys asked how's your fish
everyone how's that new grouper he's
doing well how's that uh Oscar he's
hanging in there good I was worried
about him he had the white egg ooh not
good also known as the flu for fish
don't worry you won't die just get some
chemicals in there he'll be okay
I took the kiddos to a uh my favorite
thing to do right now is go to new uh
fish stores because you never know what
they're gonna have dude they have all
sorts of different fish
um so I decided to uh
take uh the kiddos to this uh I forget
the name of it Mark's uh tropical fish
in North Hollywood they had some
different fish different fish in my
normal store aquarium city is my off
Sherman Way is my uh local fish shop
they have some nice fish but uh this
place had some pretty dope fish I have
the biggest parrot fish you've ever seen
he's a problem he's not keto he's too
friendly his mouth is all messed up if
you don't know about this uh parrot
fish's mouths are different than other
fish and uh they can't bite they can't
just push each other she don't have to
worry about them killing fish but it's
tough to feed him and he he's so fat
he's so fat it's a problem he's uh he's
not Cheeto he's just not keto
um so it's not good man it's not good
you don't know what to do with them
um it I'm constantly changing water I
smell like fish all the time I smell
like fish what can you do
can I get my coffee mug from siegem
that's how you know that's how you know
you got fish on Fish on Fish seach him
sent me a bunch of stuff to keep my fish
alive we're hanging in there hanging in
there a lot of water changes chin a lot
of water changes
um but yeah that's it man spent uh
Sunday with the kiddos at Disney Boston
has never been Disney tiger grew up at
Disney
um
bossy could give two flying
um Fricks about Disneyland all he wanna
do is play with uh Bubbles and uh hug
all the characters that's all he wanted
to do did not care about rides or
nothing
which I respect oh yeah man
rage against machine I feel like he's
playing his little head all the time
he's just whatever everybody else likes
he does not like he goes against the
grain which I appreciate it'll pay off
when he's older it will pay off but uh
this isn't about my fish or about
Disneyland this is about UFC news and
what's going on and there's a lot of
news going on
um before we jump into the whole Francis
ingano drama with Dana White in the UFC
uh we had John Anakin on food truck
diary that drops on Wednesday says Casey
that drops on Wednesday and John Annex
one of my favorite people to ever do it
he's such a good dude
um he's such a damn good person he's one
of my favorite favorite people involved
in the sport and he came with the fire
kick the Rodriguez's uh dunks he came
with some fire kicks and uh he's he's
one of the guys where it doesn't I don't
have to it's not a heavy lift when John
Anna comes in you can just kind of wind
him up and let him go he's one of my
favorite people in the sport another
dude for a hot freaking second he is
such a good person man and uh
we really get into it this guy puts I
really hope no Dana talk well that's his
boss my man and David's kind of the news
so suck my big fishy dick how about that
that didn't sound good at all fishy
fishy dick
hey man that's horrible hey dude my
hands smell like fish figure it out all
right you know figure it out I just feel
like fish all the time now it's all good
man I'm married I don't have to worry
about these hoes out here worry about me
smelling like fish I just smell like a I
smell like a sailor 24 7. dude I've done
50 water changes you think you want fish
you think you want these big 80 gallon
60 gallon tanks you think you think you
want puffer fish because they look cute
and then you put in an Oscar in their
tank because you think he's strong
enough to handle their ferocious
Tendencies nah bro it'll hurt your
feelings and your son will cry it's a
nightmare dealing with puffer fish every
other fish I love Puffer
the the Jeffrey dahmers of the sea they
are they're so aggressive anyways this
is about fish this is how much I love
Johnny food truck drops Wednesday one of
my favorite guests so enjoy that and do
we mention Dana we do and I bring up the
Dana drama and uh you know I don't do
the whole gotcha stuff so uh you'll see
how it goes but John x one of my
favorite [ __ ] people on the wall
absolutely love that dude I actually
want his brother to come with him his
twin brother he's close with his brother
like I am so I want his brother to come
here but his brother was uh busy smoking
weed I think
so that's cool because in Florida he's
the Florida guy
um but yeah we got him some dope cake
shout out to suplex but that drops on
Wednesday I'm excited for this one so
let's get into it man
um I alluded to this on the food truck
dive John attic I said I can't remember
last time you know to start a new year
there's been so many black guys no pun
intended to Dana's wife uh there's been
so many black guys in mixed martial arts
especially when it comes to the UFC then
2023 it's been a tough go and we we're
not even in the end of January it's been
a tough go so I said what do you what I
think is going to happen is the UFC is
going to release a bunch of big name
fights to get the pr back on their side
you can see a bunch of fights rolling
out from here till I bet the next two
weeks you're just getting big news big
news big news big news to make us forget
about all the negativity and that's kind
of what's going on right now but UFC did
get another black eye again no pun
intended
you do get black eyes from slapping but
um
they do get another black guy because
the news was out we've all been waiting
for Francis Jon Jones fight then some
poor fella at T-Mobile was like Jon
Jones Sarah gone I'll get it up they're
like no we didn't say that he's like you
said that cool I'll do it now and then
he he didn't have a job today because he
leaked the news before the UFC and if we
learned anything from the arrow Hawaii
situation when he leaked news when they
don't want you to leak the news there's
nothing the UFC hates most they want to
control the narrative at all times and
this poor worker at T-Mobile Arena
didn't get the memo and he blasted all
over
um and you know and he got out and when
it came out my uh my team was like Hey
look Francis Sarah gone but they say
it's not real this could be fake you
know someone's just trolling the FC I
went hold on
if it's on the T-Mobile banner and it's
out there I will guarantee you this is
the fight nobody makes that mistake and
there's no way they're signing Francis
either
fast forward about eight hours later
boom it becomes official and then the
news Francis uh decided not to sign with
the FC gets released here's what I know
on Francis ingano I'll be completely
transparent
um as soon as I heard the news it bummed
me out I want Francis in the UFC for a
variety of reasons
but B I'm really close with francis's uh
agent Markell
now
when I say close you know
um I've known for
probably eight years eight years will
tax during big fights with tax with
Francis news
I was not aware that he doesn't work
with Francis anymore and hasn't for a
few months so when I heard the France
news I just text him what happened it
was beats me I don't work with him
anymore but excuse me I said well who
negotiated the deal who how did this not
get done he goes Francis represented
himself
I sent the emoji of a hanger like this
oh
I like that France wants to bet on
himself and that Francis has
the
faith in himself to get a deal done
I would consider myself
kind of a smart dude not the smartest in
the room ever any room I walk into but I
know a few things about a few things you
know when it comes to business in
regards to UFC fighters I've done a
pretty good job outside the UFC as far
as creating a business goes multiple
businesses
I've been in those negotiating rooms
I have two college degrees francis's
first language isn't even English and he
has no business degree
I'm telling you they will eat you alive
in there I've been in that room I
thought I could handle it trust me of
course it didn't go well of course it
didn't do well they have all the chips
they know every single angle you're
going to come from and they're ready for
it dude I wish I would have gotten his
hair like whoa even if you don't sign
with a lawyer hire the lawyer on an
hourly basis have them in there with you
so you know the language of what they're
telling you it's not so much that hey
we're gonna pay more than we paid Brock
Lesnar yes or no it doesn't work like
that it's very cloudy com it's it's it's
confusing they're tailing all these
angles they're bringing up this stuff
this thing you're dealing with a lot a
fighter at this point should not be
represented themselves everyone is well
sugar Shawn does or this guy does I get
it it's a little different here when
you're talking about Championship level
Fighters especially when talking about
Francis ingano who's currently the the
was the heavyweight champion of the
world it's just not the smartest route
to go
so I heard that I thought of course the
deal didn't get done
let's take a little break from chatting
your ear off about the fight game Tampa
Florida Tampa Bay Florida this Friday
Saturday only Tampa Europe get out your
Tom Brady jerseys dust off those Mike
All-Star jerseys go ahead and get out
that throwback Steve Young rookie year
Tampa Bay Buccaneer Jersey and get your
tan sweaty thick asses to the Tampa
Improv this Friday and Saturday January
20th 21st two shows Friday two shows
Saturday only we're almost sold out so
Tampa let's go baby let's do it this
[ __ ] show is brought to you by
DraftKings UFC 283 is taking the MMA
action to the next level this freaking
Saturday there are two titles on the
line and one bout is historic UFC match
with figurado facing Moreno for the
fourth freaking time check out draft
game Sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the UFC new customers
can bet just five dollars and get two
hundred dollars in free bets instantly
you have Glover texture Jamal Hill
figarito you also got Moreno fighting
for the fourth time Jamal Hill Global
texture flip a coin can Jamal Hill deal
with the five rounds in Brazil the
grappling expertise of global texture
isn't gonna be too much if he gets him
down if Clover gets on top yeah it's a
nightmare King Glover void the big
Atomic power punching Jamal Hill for 25
minutes I don't know Vegas and
DraftKings has a slight Edge towards
Hill this Not a Bad Bet but also there's
a lot of factors there he's in Brazil
it's five rounds Glover can grapple his
tail off Glover's going to learn from
his last fight with Yuri and probably
tighten up a little bit not be so sloppy
it's a fun fight tough one to pick uh
Moreno is one of my favorite Fighters so
I refuse to get better against him
against figarito but figured on Brazil
nightmare download the app right now use
code shop show Schaub show new customers
can bet five dollars on UFC 283 and get
200 in free bets instantly that's code
shop show this Saturday draftking
Sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the UFC minimum age eligibility
restrictions play see show notes for
details
this episode of the shop show is also
brought to you by audit audit.com
and you get 10 off every single thing on
the on that website but also audit
doesn't stop there they got the new deal
going on for you on its New Year all you
deal it's mid-January so you better get
on it this deal is not going to last
forever throughout January get 20 off
selected supplements and nutrition 10
off select Fitness 50 off digital items
streaming Fitness all that stuff you
don't have to leave your home you can
get your thick ass in shape that means
also Alpha Brain you get 10 off that all
right we're talking about the best
nootropic on the planet I like the Alpha
Brain Black Label gets highly
concentrated because I have issues all
right for training you can do at home
join the new all year all you on it six
challenge a six week workout lifestyle
program with over 36k in prize money up
for grabs the challenge helps you
connect with others in the audit
community so you can support each other
achieve your goals it's a fun thing to
do get in jail with your friends you can
compete against each other and you can
also make money we're talking about 36
Grand so again this January the only
this January 20 off select supplements
10 off select Fitness 50 off digital
items and you can get temperatures off
Alpha Brain and so much more stuff when
you go to audit.com all right that's all
you gotta do go to audit.com
and you save money off the best
supplements on the planet now let's get
back to the program
now
I am excited for Jon Jones Sarah gone
super excited you know the the Francis
Econo news doesn't overshadow that I'm
still excited for that fight I'm excited
for John to come back how long have I
been telling you guys if you watch this
show all the time how many how many
episodes Have I told you guys this isn't
a Jon Jones problem Jon Jones has been
ready to go wants to fight they couldn't
find him a fight they were banking on
Francis that's how they thought the
deals he had done they were banking on
Francis they didn't get done so we have
cereal gone there waiting
in the shadows
um it's a great fight and we'll get into
that fight after this what's hilarious
to me is John's a plus 100 I would put
my entire life savings on Jon Jones
beaten zero gun that's how confident I
am in that fight a plus 100 I know Vegas
wants the lines to move my God I need to
bet on it as soon as I get out of here
to make a ton of money on that fight if
Francis on one leg can out grapple Cyril
gone over five rounds
what do you think John's gonna do
easy money we'll get to that fight so it
says John's money line is sitting around
plus 110 successful 100 wage on light
heavyweight goat would bring in 110 as
for God he's a shock at minus 130
favorite oh my God take my money
DraftKings right now I'm gonna throw
down the bet I'll post it your boy's
betting big on that
before this airs and switches the the
line the money on Johnson come pouring
in that Line's Gonna Change by the time
John fights and was it March 4th by the
time John fights and I don't care if I
have a date that weekend we're canceling
we're doing a fight command for that I
don't give do I
on March 4th yeah on that Saturday yep
oh we we have to do it I can't miss
John's first fight I can't I can't
I can't
God damn it let's give me a nightmare
from anyways I can't
um back to Francis
um here's how I break this down
I love somebody who bets on themselves
like Francis that's what he's doing here
if I sit back and I take my uh
admiration for Francis zagano out of the
equation and I sit in Dana White's seat
or the UFC's brass seat and I think to
myself why wouldn't this deal get done
the UFC is banking on ju they were
banking on Jon Jones beating Francis
agano so let's say in this crazy world
we live in John were to beat Francis
what do you do with Francis let's say
John holds on to that belt for three to
four fights Francis loses to John beats
one guy gets another shot loses to him
you're not going to pay that you're not
going to give that guy the world
you're just not you're not so the whole
Dana thing in the UFC went working about
on John John's uh a valued fighter on
the roster even though he's had his
mistakes uh he's the pound-for-pound
grace of all time under most people's
perspective there so we're gonna Bank on
John to get it done we think John beats
Francis We're not gonna give we're not
going to get the deal done because
Francis would fight John and lose and
then he's just not as big of a name then
he comes back John beats him again then
he's really devalued we're gonna Bank on
John they sign a eight fight deal with
John John's gonna ride his career out
with the UFC never leave he will be that
guy who does some of the legend fights
after his heavyweight Reign and then he
retires the UFC fighter he's never gonna
go anywhere else
um so the UFC's banking on Jon Jones
France is banking on himself that's all
this is
what worries me and what I think why
when I sit back and I think and it's
just speculation but if I'm Francis
and they go we offered him Brock Lesnar
money which is a ton of money Brock
probably made between 50 and 20 million
dollars so if that's true that they're
often Brock money that's a ton of money
what would what incentive would you have
to leave if you're Francis if you're
Francis and again he knows more than all
of us
there has to be some sort of guarantee
or verbal guarantee that he has that
would make him more money than fighting
Jon Jones and whoever else in the UFC
and that would be a boxing fight so
there has to be some guarantee from
Wilder Fury
um you know some of these other big
names Anthony uh
um what's the name Anthony Joshua not so
much there but I think with Fury and
Wilder they could play ball there
um you know Andy Ruiz might be able to
play ball
um there's some other guys that he could
fight
I'm assuming this is
for Francis this is more about just
accumulating the most money possible and
the way to do that is a boxing match and
he's not too focused on mixed martial
arts and that's why he left the UFC
because if you sit back and you're
France's manager which he doesn't have
right now but if you are his manager and
you go through the other potential
organizations and who he could fight and
make that type of money I'll wait go
ahead
go ahead but give me a name Ryan Bader
and beltor you think that's going to be
be a bigger payday bigger draw than
Jon Jones no not a chance
um as far as coverage Media stuff that
don't pay your bills but it kind of does
it goes hand in hand
um name a heavyweight you'd fight in one
Championship name a guy and ryzen pfl
name a heavy in pfl
go ahead fellas I'll wait so for Francis
he has to to be able to bank on yourself
and walk away from that type of money
and that type of exposure in the UFC
there has to be some sort of negotiating
going on in the boxing world that we
don't know about that's the only valid
point I can think of why France would
turn down this insane deal to be the
highest paid uh UFC heavyweight of all
time and you know we're offering Brock
Lesnar money when I was 12 years ago at
least 10 years ago so it's like okay you
know okay
um still
there has to be potential you know [ __ ]
you money involved I assume that's
boxing so for Francis this is more than
just
mixed martial arts and his legacy in the
UFC this there has to be some sort of
guarantee in boxing that's why I walked
away
so it says Brock Lesnar made well over
five million dollars listen I know how
much Brock made when he fought Shane
Carwin I know how much Shane Carwin made
he made way more than that
so the bout earned him so Lesnar
Showdown against Mark hunt at UFC 200
was the most lucrative payday of his UFC
career of the battle earned him a
whopping 2.5 million dollars
that they reported to the commission he
made way more than that he got the
highest percentage ever for UFC fighter
as far as pay-per-view shares goes he
made
multi-multi-multi-million dollars every
time he fought that was his deal with
DFC he made so much money even Shane got
some payout from that he made so much
money
um
so again it's a lucrative contract is it
a Deontay Wilder you know Tyson Fury uh
Anthony Joshua paid eight no but as far
as UFC goes it's a big deal now is he
worth more than that yeah he should be
getting more but still for the current
times that we're in it was a good deal
for him I
the only thing that allowed me to sleep
last night was assuming that he has some
sort of boxing deal coming down the
pipeline otherwise he made a terrible
mistake
now we're going to learn pretty soon
here I'm sure we get some news what
exactly francis's options are because if
there's no boxing big payday in the
horizons he made a horrible mistake
banking on himself here
because you're right off in the sunset
you might get paid some a little more at
first but in a lot in the long run
you're not going to make as much as you
would in the UFC it's just not you're
just not buddy but they're the only
thing I have to ride on is there's a big
boxing payday in his future that's it
so one thing we have to bank on
and the UFC's banking on Jon Jones
beating Sarah gone they're banging on
beating Francis Gano which I agree with
them if I was gonna put you know money
let's say they were stocks I would bet
on John over Francis
what I don't like about this whole thing
is Dana devouring Francis why not just
say we just can't come to the terms he
wants to box we want an MMA but he
really want this box thing we're not
going to set that kind of standard for
fighters to box and do this so we
decided to let him go
you don't have to say friends want to
fight easier competition and we offer
the most money possible but you want to
fight easier competition outside the UFC
that doesn't work for me you're talking
about a guy in France and Ghana who
fought 0 gone possibly the most talented
heavyweight on the planet not named Jon
Jones the most athletic guy Savage he
fought him on one leg and beat him and
you look at France's resume who's he
ever been scared of that doesn't work
for me there was no need to devalue the
Francine Ghana in this press conference
I hate that I absolutely hate that
I but I would say this is a black guy
for the UFC again you let the number one
heavyweight on the planet walk away
but I think the number one heavy around
the planet we're not hearing from him
right now his whole thing is getting
this big [ __ ] you money from boxing he's
also I think 35 36 coming off a leg
entry now I was talking with somebody
who's balls deep in the UFC and he go I
go man how could they let this happen he
goes we don't know how bad his injury
was
as far as post-surgery we don't know uh
if it's still affecting him if he's ever
gonna be the same he's 36 so he's long
on the tooth when he comes on fighting
um
now I did talk to people close with
Francis they go no no
he's been full sparring training he's
beating the [ __ ] out of guys he looks
fantastic his leg is an issue at all
who knows it's all speculation who knows
but there's a few factors is he the same
guy does he have that big boxing fight
in the pipeline you know there's a lot
of stuff to consider here
for the UFC it's a black guy but they're
banking on John I don't blame him
I don't blame him at all we bummed out
chin
no you weren't bummed out I'm just
bummed out I want Francis to have this
big box and fight and get the [ __ ] you
money and get 40 million dollars right
off of the sunset that's the best case
scenario worst case that never happens
we haven't heard much about the fury
fight not much about the Wilder fight
right so you haven't heard any of that
talk lately outside those two gentlemen
to get [ __ ] you money there's really
nobody else you look at the heavyweight
division in boxing there's not a lot out
there for him is he gonna beat those
other guys probably not is he going to
beat Fury or water probably not so you
have one shot at this then after that
you know come back to MMA I'm
disappointed because I want to see
Francis John Francis hero gone again
when he's healthy
um that's why I'm bummed out yeah I mean
we wanted the Francis Jones fight but
for
as long as it lasted I started just like
giving up Hope on it so I'm like yeah
it'd be cool to see him do stuff in like
you know potentially boxing or bkfc or
something just it was just some crazy
show
it'd be kind of cool to see that
yeah I just you know UFC's always
struggle to get deals done when you
think about Fedor ran a guitar you think
about this you know this is another
hiccup there I'm just I think I love
when guys Bank of himself which France
is doing but I I just have to assume
that the big boxing paydays in the
Horizon form that's the only reason you
turn this down
and then I think Tony bellew the boxer
he's like he's he shouldn't do boxing
he's not gonna survive I don't think he
survives to make his career at it I
think he gets that one big payday yeah
and after that you know then he comes
back to MMA and does this thing there I
just wish him in the UFC could agree on
he can do that box and come back to UFC
here's the other thing
Frank this is what people are feeling
France turned down this right now maybe
he just because the UFC's like
absolutely not you can't box you have to
fight John first then then we'll see
what happens in France go nope they're
telling me this Deal's done I'd make
this much money I'm doing this this he
goes okay dude then we can't work with
you so Francis could go over fight Fury
not sign with any MMA organization and
then come back to the UFC there's that
option too
Never Say Never the UFC would take him
right away and if he gets beaten by fury
like even he gets if he gets beaten bad
we already know his chances are so low
he still would be badass coming back
that's what I'm saying yeah I don't
think it devalues him no I think UFC
want him to fight John first and then
maybe do boxing or I think UFC wasn't
they don't want to set the standard that
guys can bounce between boxes like we
let Connor do it it's become a nightmare
yeah that guy owns the [ __ ] company
his logo proper Whiskey's all over the
place we're not gonna allow that to
happen again
that's what I think happened I think the
business deal I think Francis made a few
mistakes represent himself I think
Francis knows that that boxing thing is
in the horizons hopefully it works out
for him and I think UFC goes we don't
think he can be John you beat John and
the rest that if you don't be John what
do we do with you we're not get and
we're still offering all this money but
we're not gonna let you box Francis now
I want a box now there is a world where
Francis and I don't know how it worked
most companies don't allow this whether
it's pfl one Championship Bellator
Rising we're just one-offs so say fights
Fury
does bare knuckle becomes a pfl there's
the Bellator like bounces around just
big payday big fighting Champs fighting
Champs collecting belts like Thanos
there's that yeah
I doubt that happens I I the only thing
that makes sense to me is he has a big
box announcement coming up yeah makes
sense but we it's been quiet dude
yeah but I mean I imagine it would be
the fury fight I mean
Fury has hands full with homeboy yo you
sick yes yeah
yeah but it's also like it's not even a
real boxing fight remember they wanted
to do MMA gloves yeah it's kind of like
a hybrid that won't happen it's gonna be
boxing
so I just think you know the end of the
day UFC's banking on John Francis
banking himself has a big boxing thing
in the Horizon that's it that's why it
doesn't hurt as much too just finding
out that Jon Jones is actually now he's
he's got an opponent he's in heavyweight
and all the different people can fight
in heavyweight it's so exciting you'll
see soften the blow yeah they went yep
we didn't sign Francis but check out
John over here well okay yeah all right
against anyone in heaven it's so much
fun anyone
so it's interesting man but I you know
it is a black guy for the UFC to let the
number one heavyweight in the world walk
you know yeah but remember he can come
back
he can't come back now there was uh I
think it's Photoshop there's a picture
of Francis and his uh I think his family
in pfl shirts
I don't know you know I think Jake
Paul's gonna help Francis out if he does
go over there but um
is that right there yeah
oh it says yeah someone a relative
I know pfl did want to go after him I
know bkfc belt or pfl they all they want
her to talk it's interesting too because
pfl is under the ESPN umbrella
yeah
so I don't know we're gonna get some
more clarity I assume is the few days
passes if I don't post a photo on social
media showing if I'm doing with a family
New Year dinner table my guess there was
a woman with a pfl shirt
foreign
yeah I didn't look into this so I'm not
sure how
much it that is yeah we'll see I you
know him representing himself was scary
when English your second language is
Tough Enough if you have your [ __ ]
black belt in English which I do not but
it's tough enough you know I wish him
the best and but I don't think it's the
last we have friends in the UFC I think
he does his boxing thing comes back
we'll see let's see it's some crazy
lucrative lucrative deal in pfl
you know but there's not much out there
for him to get you excited and mixed
martial arts
the Jones fight was probably the most
exciting fight that could have happened
and if Jones absolutely mops the floor
of cereal gone it's like it creates more
demand for the Francis fight yeah so
maybe France Spanky on that he goes let
him fight Sarah let's see how it goes so
for what you do boxing and come back if
what you say comes true then let's say
Francis does the boxing stuff even if he
gets knocked out in boxing we all expect
that he should get knocked down in
boxing but if he does well like pfl
belts or whatever and then comes back to
the UFC and then fights Jon that'll be
freaking huge because John only gets
bigger John mops the floor So Gone John
star gets bigger Francis has all this
hype around him let's say France does
that box and goes decent his star is
bigger than ever and then you sign the
deal yeah maybe that's what friends are
doing maybe yeah all speculations cool
that he's betting on himself man that's
pretty dope it is you just have to hope
that he actually this box of stuff comes
fruition because if the plan is just to
negotiate and deal with other MMA
companies it's not the move it's just
not the best competitions in the UFC
period specially at heavyweight
I know Curtis blades who we had on food
truck and that releases later this month
is gonna be fresh he's frustrated I know
he put out a thing but he has to be
frustrated you know
but I remember reading it it just said
him saying like he understands who puts
the most yeah
it is and he hopes to be that person
after his next fight
um
all right let's read this curse blades
tweet he put obviously I've seen the
news gone is getting another title shot
versus Jones most likely I'll begin
Pavlich who just beat uh
giovasa that's cool with me
she says I get why gang got the shot and
it wasn't based off meritocracy
that's not news flash you if she's
always gonna make the
fight based off who puts the most asses
in the stands and eyes on the fight I
hope uh I hope I'll only need one more
win to prove I can put asses in the
stands and get a tile shot you know
yeah I love Curtis
and Stipe said March 4th I like it I get
the winner in July that big July summer
card [ __ ] yeah John's Depot
John anyone in heavyweight it's so much
fun yeah for sure
so there you have it yeah we'll see what
happens hope it works out best for
everybody how about Brett uh akamoto
kind of going at Dana a little bit did
he yeah during the press conference
he went at him Dana was ready though
which I'm sure you know
did it was
privy to what was going on before he sat
down I know there was one reporter I
don't know his name whatever but that
did you know kept digging yeah kept
digging which I was that was pretty cool
the thing on data where he's like
he's like it hurts it hurts the UFC one
hurts me if you punish me and he's like
you know
what's the punishment he's like what do
you want me to do the punishment I'm
already labeled this guy for the rest of
my life correct the correct thing to say
would been it's not to me what the
punishment is you guys decide I'm down
for whatever I'll accept whatever you
guys give me but instead he's like you
punishing me is actually hurting
yourself it's like Ugh
that's not narcissist to the fullest my
God
he said the fighters uh his company
yeah they're the ones that will be
punished if he's not there but then and
we we all discussed this before I'm sure
the company is pretty established they
know what they're doing they can do
pretty well without Dana at least if he
was suspended for maybe like a month or
two or something like that yeah it would
be fun they'd be fine yeah
here's here's the question let's say
daily got
um
fired had to step down for whatever
reason you know for slapping his wife
beating her up who fills in for him
yeah I don't know
Mick Banyan
I'm not sure I've ever heard John Shelby
I'm not I don't think I've ever heard
them talk Hunter Campbell yeah I heard
he's awesome 100 I heard Hunter's
awesome behind the scenes but I haven't
haven't heard them really speak and be
like a front person no you mentioned DC
I think DC would be great too but you
have DC Brian Stan Yeah Tim Kennedy
I
I don't know who'd want to do it to be
honest John Annex too friendly Rogan
doesn't have time for it yeah
let's take a little break kids Break
Time Hug time this new year you've got
goals and factors here to help you
achieve your goal all right listen if
you want to get in shape you want to get
shred everyone thinks just go to the gym
but keep eating like you do nope diet is
90 of people who are lean and are
getting shredded that's where Factor can
help you out factors ready to eat meals
are delivered straight to your door get
Factor not only skip the trip to the
growth store but skip the chopping the
prepping the cleaning forget all that
stuff factors fresh never frozen meals
are ready in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat up and enjoy no
matter what your lifestyle whatever
goals you have whatever diet you have
Factor got you covered they have keto
calorie smart vegan veggie extra protein
protein plus prepared by chefs approved
by dietitians each meal has all the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long right looking to cut back
on takeout we'll get Factor instead not
only is Factor cheaper than takeout but
meals are ready quicker than restaurant
delivery 2 min it can Uber or Postmates
deliver in two minutes nope Factor wins
again get Factor enjoy clean eating
without the hassle simply choose your
meal enjoy fresh flavor-packed meals
delivered straight to your door ready in
two minutes all right achieve and
maintain your goals this year with
Factor get America's number one ready to
eat meal kit start saving time eating
well and living your best year ever had
to factor
f-a-c-t-o-r75.com shop 60 use the cop
code Cod you I wish that God I don't eat
fish though uh use the code shop 60 get
60 off your first box that's code shop
60 SCH ab60 at factor75.com shop 60 to
get 60 off your first box enjoy this
episode of the shop show is also brought
to you by the best freaking
Nitro for your brain if you wanna be
smarter you want to fire up those
neurons in your brain you want to get
that brain work at the full capacity
that's meant to be you need your
Limitless bill you need Kratom you need
the not just any Kratom trade them you
can trust from my friends at happy hippo
it's the only Kratom I trust it's easy
to digest I take the little high
concentrated Cherry shots it comes in
this cute little pink bottle two of
those your boys Off to the Races they
have gummies however you want to get
your Kratom they have powders they're
the best of the best Kratom is the wild
west out there but you need to trust my
friends a Happy Hippo I asked them be on
the show because I used to create them
all the time and I trust them and you
guys trust me so here we are happy
hippo's the best creative on the planet
all you got to do is go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23
that's t h i c c 23 thick with three C's
23 and you save 20 off your entire order
you ensure that code as many times as
you want share with your friends
whatever you want to do 20 off for life
all you do is use thick 23 thick with
three C's that's Happy hippo.com promo
code thick23 for the best Kratom on the
freaking planet you're welcome now let's
get back to the program
all right Jim what do you got
oh okay so we did have the fights over
the weekend where
um as you know Kelvin gaslin had to
um
bounce out of the fight so I do like
this fight better yeah that's why I was
more excited for because Rashawn
Strickland for getting to win you know
he needed you lose three in a row to be
tough yeah said the UFC paid him a ton
of money to take a short notice fight I
love that he got done with the win he
wins you don't have his decision
and then goes at the judges who just
gave me unanimous decision
it was kind of funny the only reason I'm
here is because he's shitty judges like
but they just give a unanimous decision
yeah that makes sense but I get it he's
upset first pass yeah yeah Danny yay
look phenomenal you need that one I love
just post fight speech yeah
Raquel Penton that was a close one
uh um
looked phenomenal my God that knockout
was bad it didn't look like he landed
flat like he landed flesh but we've seen
harder shots especially for guys never
been knocked out
that left hook got it done
umar's uh undefeated at bantamweight
that kid's a problem
um Abdul razak I was so funny after the
fight too would you say he the Abdul Raz
I'll play a little clip for me but he's
super funny after the fight this is my
boy Cody Donovan gosh in Denver yeah
he's a high altitude guy Savage
somebody's about to get knocked down
that fight they were going at it man
what's the clip he's going at uh Joaquin
Buckley right yeah yeah let me see it
pretty hard real quick so Sean
Strickland his post fight speech too he
was talking about how uh even though
he's getting paid a lot now he's like he
referenced Stefan Bonner you know he's
kind of saying like everyone kind of
like wrote him off all the old school
guys that pretty much built the UFC they
got paid [ __ ] compared to what they're
getting paid now and people write them
off and they make fun of them now and
all that stuff and he's like equals even
me I blocked Stefan Bonner but I'm not a
regular person I'm like an animal this
tablet he deserves better and all that
stuff he said a lot of cool stuff on in
the post fight uh conference yeah I mean
Sean says some wild [ __ ] which is why we
love him but sometimes that wild [ __ ]
kind of pollutes the good stuff he says
like just stance on Bonner when
everyone's posting pictures spot on yeah
the stuff about you know these veterans
when they're done he's like they have
nothing man you just don't understand
they have nothing you guys just forget
about them let me see what uh Abdul says
here I wonder if I have a better clip
here though so I'll play this for now
hopefully it lands on the
I thought I was able to change it I
think it starts here
I heard this guy in training is a
[ __ ] Savage he looks like a Savage
he's mad at Buckley shot
that's why you're so mad yeah
they made an agreement beforehand as
soon as he felt his power shot but I
mean I just think this guy's a character
now I never even know oh yeah but he's
super fun
he's really upset someone shot on him
you're a business martial arts you're a
[ __ ]
I can't get too good to this
Jesus Christ he's upset yeah okay so we
found out more stuff about James cross
Jesus Christ and I try to look into this
a lot it's hard for me to understand
what these things are if it's illegal or
not but so James cross was as this
article says on bjpen.com reportedly
worked as an agent for offshore sports
book prior to prior to his suspension
and then I saw this part of the article
it says for the uninitiated an agent in
the world of betting is the term for a
middleman between offshore Sports books
and Bettors and according to sources
closest across he would provide people
with a line of credit and login
credentials
and then they would place you know their
bets
on the site as well as pay him directly
so I guess and it says right here it's
worth noting that U.S residents who have
worked as agents for offshore Sports
books have previously been charged with
a Litany of crimes those crimes are tax
evasion operating illegal sports betting
organization and money laundering ish
so it looks like it's getting even
deeper and deeper I told you guys from
from my sources who are a close
situation he he's gonna be spending some
time behind some bars yeah this is this
runs deep deep way deeper than we know
and uh Jeff Molina who we found out
recently I think was released I don't
know if he's suspended but I think it
was released from the UFC yeah he was um
so this there's a Discord message that
was leaked and ESPN I guess ESPN got a
hold of it so it says
he says he trained with a lot of
Fighters lives and breathed the sport as
a coach a fighter at times has the scoop
on injuries not an ounce match-ups how
Fighters looking Camp Molina wrote in
the Discord leaked uh ESPN in stocks
this is called insider trading MMA
betting it's called James Krauss for the
last six months all my bills include
mortgage and car note have been paid for
Via Cruise picks do yourself a favor and
join the VIP which is there a thing that
you know people could sign up for
and ever since then everything's just
gone
yeah so it's getting deeper and heavier
so apparently James cross is probably
going to go away for for some time now
yeah yeah
all right good now
um all right so we already knew this is
going to happen but now it's official
Leon Edwards versus Camaro Usman three
well we all thought was gonna be Leon
mod because camarosman's been taking
pictures yeah yeah but thank God that's
happening yeah so that's the March 2 UFC
286
and on that same card apparently this is
done I feel physiv and Justin Gucci dog
coming in hot yeah I told juice he's
gonna start announced some big boy
fights yep and then also d-rod against
Gunner Nelson Gunner fight in a hot
second yep
and this is what the card looks like so
far all this here take my money yeah
yeah it's pretty good
um
so this I thought was kind of crazy so
Diego Sanchez is gonna fight Austin
Trout who's a legit boxer that's
logistic yeah in bkfc on February 17th
I don't like that I looked at Austin
Trout's record he's uh Savage yeah 35
and five won his last five fights
so yeah I don't know how that's gonna
work out for Diego did he fight Jamal
Charlo went to the [ __ ] decision
what is I know man but the only thing is
in the spirit knuckle like we've seen it
with Perry and with uh Michael Venom
page sometimes the technique and like
the pretty stuff doesn't do well it
doesn't farewell on bare knuckle
yeah so if Diego like makes a little
brawl gets in his face like Mike paired
against Michael Venom page sometimes you
can Edge out the decision
yeah and it's a nightmare formula you
know Diego's older man I I don't like it
I don't like they still fighting yeah of
course not
uh wait wasn't Paulie malinagi and be
KFC am I tripping no he was getting lost
right yeah it's hard yeah so yeah it
doesn't make a difference when you're
when doing a bare knuckle
um all right so this is uh they did
Bellator is doing an another lightweight
Grand Prix I guess tournament and then
Benson Henderson your boy will be
fighting undefeated Usman
[ __ ] made officer nightmare yeah he's
just
these [ __ ] guys dude if you have that
last name don't fight them
go go Ben Henderson though but God damn
dude tough one yeah there's a bunch of
other good fights there but that's like
the one
that caught my attention
so this isn't guaranteed but Alistair
over him apparently is in talks with one
Championship because they're gonna do a
a Muay Thai Grand Prix with a million
dollar grand prize and then so
shot trees that you don't announced it
and then apparently uh Alistair hit him
up asking like ooh if he could be
potentially right this is going excuse
me
yeah I love that open weight Grand Prix
yep
what should be great for Alistair Chachi
said this thing's gonna blow up you're
going to see big guys against small guys
it's going to be huge and he said
there's gonna be multiple ex-ufc
Fighters I love this
all right
this is kind of crazy
uh this is LFA oh I saw saw this
let's saw a clip of it okay you guys
hold on to that choke ninja choke and
then the referee just didn't stop it and
then people are kind of debating how
long that choke was on before the guy
was out and apparently I mean if you
look at the clip here oh yeah
I'll just show you hold on
[Music]
and the referee should know clear the
referee's not a Grappler right here this
thing's over yeah to me the guy looks
just like he's right here
right there you see his shoulder like
season up yeah it's over stop it here
[Music]
that's not choki can fight no side's not
even hand fighting his arms aren't
moving yeah it just seems like he's kind
of like his body's just breathing or
trying to breathe but you see how he's
like going like this
how do you not grab the arm if you're
the rest to make sure he's alive
and this goes on for a while oh dude
he's probably in that choke for how long
three minutes
three minutes but it's a long time
figure it out dude
and he's like stiff
that's on the ref no what the [ __ ]
you're looking at dude so many people
are you know saying it's ridiculous she
get fired yes suspend it on especially a
joke like that and he's not hand
fighting what do you think he's doing
down there [ __ ] yeah
so I wanted to check up on I looked up
his name and see how he's doing I
couldn't find anything but then I looked
at his uh Instagram his most recent
Instagram post was just him talking
about being at the fight tomorrow
so I have no idea what's going on there
yeah his name's Scott Ritz
the guy that got choked out well sorry
sorry the ref doesn't know what the hell
he's doing buddy sorry Scotty
here's a quick one
Joe Rogan always talks about how uh in a
way showed the pride contract about
steroids like they'll test for other
stuff but not steroids that's basically
like we're not testing for steroids yeah
they'll test for like other kind of
drugs but not steroids and then he kind
of he just recently put out this uh
this video on Twitter
steroids-based family are specifically
excluded from the scope of the test yeah
so it's exclusively excluded yeah
meaning do them
those were the good days yeah
but we all knew they were like yeah
uh this is a quick update on Dylan
Dennis Scott Coker says he still has a
contract with uh Dylan Downs still has a
contract with Bellator so they're going
to honor it and they're asking if you
want to do the London fights that are
coming up and he said he wanted to do it
but uh Scott's like it is on Arrow show
it's got like a but does he really want
to keep fighting like they have no idea
but they're still going to honor that
contract yeah we had him scheduled to do
a food truck Diaries before he backed up
the KSA fight and he wants to come on
it's tough for my angle too it's like
he's gonna show up or yeah you know it's
a flight from New York to come here
we're gonna set up Hotel all this stuff
and it's like
there's a lot of planning involved oh
yeah yeah it's like do you do it you
know is he gonna show up what are we
going to talk about besides the KSI
stuff which
you know I like the kid I like that he
seems like a nice guy a lot of people
hate him you know a nice guy but I don't
know stud yeah
all right so real quick another quick
one with Bellator AJ McKee
who's their guy I guess he signed a new
multi-year deal with them so he's not
gonna go I know I was really hoping he'd
come to the UFC he's the one Prospect or
you know not even a prospect champ that
I think could do well in the UFC for
military I was really hoping to come to
the UFC but you know good for him yeah
seems like a Bellator guy he said what
do you say Fame doesn't pay my mortgage
some [ __ ] like that I didn't hear that
ever oh yeah makes sense
stud
and this one I think we can
you be the judge okay so I think we can
play the audio but I'm not sure so this
is Nate Diaz and I guess the freaking
49ers use them
for this whole hype up thing
well there's one thing that football
players respect more than another
football player it's a UFC fighter yeah
this whole thing's based off of Nate
which is really crazy and the Niners who
I think is my Dark Horse to go to the
Super Bowl I think Bills win it but I
think it's Bill's Niners sorry everybody
all right
[Music]
it's not him narrating over it is it
yeah everybody's a gangster until a
gangster walks in the room
it seems simple because it is
it's easier to talk to talk
okay you got to back it up
every team wants to be a bully they want
to play Smash Mouth
until they get smacked in their mouth
when you come from California you want
to be the best in the game
you got to be the biggest baddest mother
every time you take the field
we can't teach toughness
you can't fake guts
you're gonna have to earn them
the whole world brought us out that
we're cooked
instead of tapping out just going back
again and again pretty balling too it's
irrelevant balling
it does against the world
if you're not on our team then oh
this ain't about nobody else it's about
us
time for talk is over
time to put up or shut up
who wants it more
[Applause]
the Quest for six Starts Now
it's like all Nate I dig it yeah I dig
it not the most energy and I dig it
that's how he is that's just how he is
yeah Niners destroyed them too boy have
you seen this clip of Serial God I
haven't impersonating Nate this is
freaking amazing
today
really why what's going on Nate
considering it's still gone who's
completely different than me it's just
so funny it actually looks like Nate
yeah
and I just saw this recently from Bert
Crusher I guess he was with uh Conor
McGregor oh wow the black Fortune
in Ireland yeah so you sure enough got
the belt I mean Bert's just doing the
damn thing yeah he's having so much fun
out there
I love bird
yeah next time you go to Ireland you
should definitely go
to yeah for gin yeah yeah
we're trying to line up a Europe tour uh
this year
all right so Israel Auto Sanya posted
this on his social media he got a tattoo
finally got face like multiple face
tattoos and a neck tattoo uh I thought
he's had the Knack oh no brand new neck
one oh really yeah so we got multiple
face ones that look like he's gonna cry
there
but see that's one a brand new one on
top of his eyebrow okay I feel good
and then if you look at the video
I would never do it but I love them huh
so you'll see like a little flash of a
anime
I want to see if you can see it here
right
there
so apparently there's an anime character
in Naruto that has like a you know some
sort of writing on his eye you know
above his eyebrows so he's balls deep in
that anime stuff huh oh this is a super
funny too this someone just made this
video I ought to sign his dad trying to
remove the tattoo from his face
foreign
[Music]
I love it he looks sweet like that you
know champ oh that's filthy it's a dying
pigeon
like this
but it looks sick dude I'm about to eat
a flower head fish on my [ __ ] nut
dude that with a big head would be sick
and then
I dig it man you look sweet
yeah that pigeon is sick there's a
tattoo here too yeah it's dope yeah
no he pulled off yeah it's a dead pigeon
right I don't know what it is it's just
a bird
does it look like a dead pigeon
yeah
either way sick though pretty cool
is that a tune that's it I've got the
fights all right man yeah you'll see
coming back baby and that's a bunch of
fights you have a big UFC pay-per-view
this weekend in Brazil John anik is
supposed to wear the kicks I gave him I
don't want to spoil what kicks again
he's supposed to wear it during the
Wayne so we shall see if he does we'll
be blasting all over uh shout out to
John annik I should have wore a shirt
one more sleep
damn it d5k
it's at home oh [ __ ]
oh wait uh I went on King this thing and
find a kid Wednesday I'll make up for it
uh but you have a big pay-per-view this
freaking Saturday I will be in Tampa
unfortunately but this is since it's in
Brazil's the earlier fight no same time
7 P.M okay well that sucks for me but
good for you guys unless you're coming
by show in Tampa but then just spoil it
for me when we do the meet and greets
and let me know who won uh but I'm in
Tampa this Friday and Saturday two shows
Friday two shows Saturday only Tampa
Florida Tampa Improv and then February
3rd through the 4th Springfield Missouri
Naples Florida February 16th through the
18th Bakersfield is one night only
February 23rd get your tickets Brea I
have to figure out now all right
Oklahoma City's early March
um but you have a big UFC this freaking
Saturday the first pay-per-view of the
year you have Global Tech chair Jamal
Hill who we had on food truck about
three months ago Jamal is a complete
Savage this fight is in Brazil
um
what what are the odds on this chin what
what's the the card's pretty stacked
there
Jamal's a slight favor see yeah I'm with
him on this I think Jamal Hill should
get this done and clip Glover the
problem is Glover's uh grappling and
especially and also Glover's experience
in the later rounds you know so we'll
see uh great fight though Jamal Hill
could do some real damage there the
fight that I can't wait for is Brian
Moreno uh figarito was this their fourth
fight correct fourth fight uh it's a
minus 110. I can't agree more with Vegas
uh better even have done that I'm taking
Brad Moreno one of my favorite Fighters
nice guy on the roster uh Gilbert Burns
Neil magni the gazelle back in Action
tough fight for Neil magni magni unless
you unless he's fighting pots and nebul
really only loses the high level Jutsu
guys don't get it twisted if Gilbert
Burns wants to he can take you down and
submit you I'll take uh I'm not gonna
pick against Neil if I was a betting man
bet with uh my head not my heart Gilbert
via submissions Not a Bad Bet tough
fight for Neil magni especially in
Brazil Jessica and Josh Lauren Murphy
phenomenal fight Paul Craig Johnny
Walker I just I love Paul Craig love
Paul Craig uh he I think he's the last
one to beat uh Shogun he'd definitely
beat Shogun Johnny Walker I always root
for Johnny Walker I want to see him get
back to what he's supposed to be we
could do something like heavyweight uh
you have Shogun fighting I think this is
his last fight right
um a bunch of good fights on this card
man
Trish McKinney is phenomenal uh who else
you got on there solid fights man
Cody stamen doing the damn thing Shogun
bunch of Brazilians uh but that that
many cards worth the money in itself uh
I will take
that that Glover Jamal hell is such a
tough fight to pick so is it come in
figarito Brandon rhino
in Brazil
I'm gonna take Mourinho I'll take
Mourinho Hill
Burns andrage
and Paul Craig
doesn't mean that's who I'm rooting for
though I'll say that but enjoy the fight
this Saturday ought to be on stage in
Tampa but I'll be able to watch it after
if you're doing the meet and greet go
ahead and spoil the fight picks for me
you guys can do it anyways all good baby
that's how it goes but Tampa you're up
uh kicking off 2023 oh heathic tour
Tampa Florida January 20th 21st
Springfield Missouri February 3rd
through the 4th Naples Florida February
16th through the 18th Bakerfield one
night only February 23rd Oklahoma City
one of my favorite clubs Bricktown
economy Club March 9th through the 11th
Tacoma's on there Atlanta a bunch of
bunch of dates on there all right but
Tampa you're up right now and then
Springfield Missouri come get some baby
tickets at thickboy.com or fatkz.com I
think that's it kids a lot of drama gone
the UFC I think Francis time will tell
if you made the right decision UFC's
banking on John France banking himself
can't be mad at that I hope you guys
enjoyed the show thank you for watching
thanks tuning in remember John annik
food truck diary drops Wednesday it's a
good one you guys will enjoy it so make
sure you check that on thick boy YouTube
only and that's it kids love you be safe
see you next time I'm out if you're in
the thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding